one of the big stories in the tech
industry right now that not a lot of
people are talking about is that
everyone is leaving silicon valley and
the legacy incumbent tech companies and
they are joining bitcoin in
cryptocurrency industry now of course
there's tons of people who say it would
be an amazing job to work at facebook or
google amazon twitter and many many
other great companies but ultimately the
people have worked at those businesses
for a number of years now they're
leaving they're hitting the door and
they're going to the frontier the
bitcoin and crypto industry provides
asymmetry for your career like nothing
else available anywhere else what it
means is that you can join regardless of
your skill set regardless of your
location you can get paid more money you
can have more upside and ultimately you
can actually have more impact we are
watching one industry simply gain global
adoption in real time it's gone from
almost nothing to now three trillion
dollars in total market cap there's
everything from equity companies that
are building infrastructure and
centralized manners similar to the old
companies just in the crypto industry or
there's also all these brand new token
projects that people are working on and
so there are thousands literally
thousands and thousands of open roles
and all of the top companies across the
industry and people can't seem to hire
fast enough and so whenever you have a
misbalance in the supply and demand of a
market of course price steps in to
accommodate everyone and that's what
we're watching is people are leaving
their legacy jobs those old antiquated
dinosaur companies in the tech industry
and they're joining that frontier of
bitcoin and crypto we've got this quote
here that explains exactly what folks
are seeing intersection growth partners
says we are unquestionably seeing some
of the best and brightest silicon valley
or tech move over to crypto i've been at
this a long time i've never seen a
change happen this quickly and then
we've got a second quote here that
explains exactly what broke the dam that
was coinbase in alex zukowski's view it
was really the first one to get some
very big hires from places like google
linkedin and lyft now you're seeing some
very former senior people at the ubers
amazons pinterest atlassians and
spacex's that have jumped into this and
they're going to be recruiting from
their networks once the snowball starts
to roll downhill there's no stopping it
the best the brightest the most talented
they want to go where innovation is
happening they want to go where economic
returns are happening and there's no
better place than the bitcoin and crypto
industry if you're talented if you are
looking for a challenge quit your old
job get the hell out of there and come
join us on the frontier